throughout this war there have been
reports of Ukrainian children being
taken by Russians we'd come to an
orphanage outside her son to investigate
its director Vladimir is one of this
War's Heroes unnoticed till now
when Russia took the area he told me he
knew what he had to do
we saw Russian propagandists saying that
they need to take the orphans to give
them to military schools indoctrinate
them and let them fight for our shampoo
it was the scariest thing so we started
Hiding Children because we understood
they would take them
The Children Here were among the most
vulnerable orphans or in care and
Vladimir's fears were it turns out well
founded exclusive CCTV footage obtained
by Sky News captures the chilling moment
the Russians arrived to find the
children
agents with Russia's secret police the
FSB leading Soldiers with rifles through
a building that should be a place of
sanctuary
They confiscated all the children's
files because they couldn't figure out
where the children were so they took
files they took computers because they
wanted to know where the children had
gone
they'd gone because the community had
hidden them the entire Village rallied
together to protect the children
agreeing to take them in two or three
per family it was a remarkable Act of
Courage had any of them been exposed to
the Russians by collaborators they could
have been arrested or shot
but the Russians also sent 15 Ukrainian
orphans from Elsewhere for the orphanage
to look after
as their video show staff took them in
and treated them as their own
when Russian forces finally retreated
from the region they came and took all
15 children with them
teacher Roxanna showed us the bags of
their belongings their keeping in case
they ever return
this military vehicles and taken away
Soldiers with machine guns so of course
the children were scared and didn't know
where it's ever been taken
they weren't the only ones we went to
investigate claims Russians took much
younger children from this orphanage in
central her son
Italia who lives next door says she
watched children as young as three four
and five being taken away by the Russian
military
of course I'm worried about them they're
small children they just abandoned
children we do not know where they are
what happened to them or where they were
taken Ukrainian authorities say Russians
took 48 orphans those three to five from
here
they say 13 000 children have been
deported or abducted by Russia during
the war only some have made it back
among them 14 year old Vlad who says
Russians tried to indoctrinate the
Ukrainian children they'd taken
they said ukrainians were Nazis they
said Harrison is Russian that Crimea is
Russian I started to be a little afraid
because I wanted to go home and I didn't
want to stay there
floods back but home is a city under
regular Russian shelling
Vladimir in his village claimed to have
saved 52 children from the clutches of
the Russians but not the other 15
orphans taken by them
the Abduction of children is a grave
violation of the rules of War Ukrainian
officials say 97 orphans were taken by
the Russians from the Harrison region
alone
Dominic wagorn Sky News Cresson